good sir thank you very much Lillian
thank you for working hello at the
Internet
I'm cow I'm Dan with the slow mo guys
and sometimes something happens on the
internet it ends up on Reddit and red it
beckons us for we saw a picture of some
jelly or jello whoever it is it was
being cut up by a tennis racket when it
was hitting it into the little squares
if you see here so we're gonna try and
emulate that in slow motion you don't
even get the whole thing it was
basically a still picture and I'm gonna
do the slow-mo so we got variety of
colors and we'd ever starting with some
red so I'm some lovely red alright well
the chances this will go right the first
time
good stick man oh God
you
we need to film it better but proof of
concept
[Music]
I'm gonna go for a tight one which you
have to be really precise and where you
hit it
see it's got to be right in that window
so getting this in frame and in focus
gonna be relatively difficult be if you
can nail that that'd be a class shot
they'll be absolutely wonderful ready
not bad on focus oh yeah they're like
individual snakes yeah that's like a
quick way to make a bunch of gummy worm
joking that's how they do in the factory
just someone's knocking
[Music]
so far all we've done is replicate the
picture we saw yeah feel like it
wouldn't be a slo-mo ghost video and if
we didn't add sort of a slow-mo touch to
it right you can see what it's going
going where's the good I'm gonna get
covered in jelly or something or what
the chances that I'm gonna completely
MIT they're quite high yeah I feel like
I'm
[Music]
[Music]
oh I brought my like my eyelids
extruding to move cuz it's all sticky oh
it's horrible
ah so minging it looks incredible though
my eyebrows my eyelashes are all stuck
together I really want to go and wash my
face off you know like when you get like
just your fingers are stickers yeah oh
oh I can imagine that is way worse than
that it's all look like my arm here the
joint here is all sticking together got
some snacks on your shoulder that I
sucked it up and went up in there well
thanks to those of you on reddit who
sent that to us or tweet it to us saying
we should recreate it feel free to do
that in future we'll do it as soon as
possible you can subscribe to us on
Twitter you can buy shirts Jellicoe
t-shirt some shirt singers and we got
poster as well do you want fancy to be
alerted to every new upload subscribe
hit the little bell thing on the app
it's all good stay informed stay in
school
slow mo guys I'm gonna go and shower
this is absolutely minging can't stand
before this video ends i just want to
give a lovely shout out to the guys at
new egg who offered to send me a bunch
of pc parts for me to build a new pc and
i'll be using it to store and convert
phantom footage way faster than I could
before so if you're building a PC be
sure to check out new AK the links in
the description thanks